[Música]
por décadas nuestro cerebro ha sido
visto como esto por muchísimos años
nuestro cerebro ha sido una caja negra
en la que el mejor de los casos
llegábamos a ver que ciertos estímulos
en esa caja negra tenían una serie de
consecuencias
pero rara vez sabíamos qué era lo que
estaba pasando en realidad en esa en esa
caja negra hasta recientemente empezamos
a entender a través de tecnología
mediante
imágenes principalmente empezamos a
entender los mecanismos que tenía el
cerebro para responder a esos a esos
estímulos a esto le hemos llamado a
neurociencia la idea de la neurociencia
es básicamente ese utilizar tecnología
para entender cómo funciona esta caja
negra atrás tras bambalinas
una vez posiblemente de los
descubrimientos más interesantes y más
importantes de la neurociencia es esta
idea de dónde está el límite nuestro
límite propio pero principalmente el
límite de nuestra mente y el límite de
nuestro cerebro hasta hace poco asumimos
que el límite de nuestro cerebro era el
cerebro
hace algunos años se descubrió una
teoría que ha sido demostrada
recientemente que se llama en body
cognition y básicamente lo que quiere
decir es que no pensamos nada más con el
cerebro sino que también pensamos con el
cuerpo y a partir de esa teoría se
desarrolló una segunda que también se ha
sido sumamente demostrada recientemente
y esta segunda teoría se llama extender
comprensión la idea de extender
conclusiones que si en realidad pensamos
con el cerebro y con el cuerpo entonces
también pensamos con los espacios que
nos rodean y con las herramientas que
creamos
la consecuencia de esta teoría es que
los límites de nuestro cerebro en
realidad no están en nuestro cerebro
sino que los límites de nuestro cerebro
están en el ambiente y en el entorno que
habitamos
la primera conclusión de esto es que la
arquitectura y el espacio en realidad
entonces es cognición y esto a mis
colegas en muchas ocasiones les ponen
muy nerviosos porque esta idea del
espacio como cognición viene a tirar
por lo menos 200 años de teoría
arquitectónica en la historia de la
arquitectura nunca nadie me dijo que la
arquitectura de la cognición en el mejor
de los casos eran las descripciones como
le corbusier que decía que la
arquitectura eran bellos objetos bajo la
luz pero nadie se había cuestionado que
la arquitectura podía ser parte de
nuestros procesos cognitivos
en este empalme de empezar a entender el
impacto que tiene el espacio surge una
nueva disciplina realmente reciente y es
más tan reciente que en muchas ocasiones
ni siquiera nos hemos terminado de poner
de acuerdo en el nombre de esta
disciplina pero algunos le llamamos
neuro arquitectura y básicamente la
neuro arquitectura es cómo construyes
puentes entre los científicos que están
entendiendo cómo funcionamos cómo
percibimos cómo funciona la memoria y
los que creamos arquitectura
el sueño que tenemos la gran mayoría de
los que estamos en esta en esta
disciplina nueva es que en un futuro
cercano estamos convencidos que
deberíamos de tener la capacidad de
sanar o de curar con arquitectura el
sueño guajiro de todos los que estamos
investigando ya invirtiendo nos en la
arquitectura para la cognición es que
dentro de muy poco ustedes puedan ir o
cualquiera de nosotros podamos ir con un
doctor y para ciertos padecimientos
principalmente de salud mental te puedan
recomendar o dar una receta de qué tipo
de espacio tendrías que habitar
pero de la misma manera que la
arquitectura puede curar y puede sanar
la arquitectura puede hacer daño
en esta búsqueda de como la arquitectura
puede hacer daño creo que de lo que nos
va a empezado a suceder dentro de muy
poco es que vamos a tener que empezar
nos a plantear los que estamos los que
somos responsables de crear arquitectura
y no es nada más los arquitectos es los
que el que contrata a un arquitecto el
que construye el que administra todos
los que tenemos que ver con el espacio
construido vamos a tener que empezar a
cuestionar si no tendríamos que hacer
una especie de juramento hipocrático si
la arquitectura puede curar y puede
hacer daño tendríamos que por lo menos
estar seguros que si no vamos a ayudar
en el peor de los casos
que por lo menos podamos no hacer daño y
en esta idea de cómo hacer la
arquitectura daño hace algunos años
empezamos a cuestionarnos muchísimo en
el despacho cómo podíamos identificar si
la arquitectura estaba haciendo daño o
no porque si mi sueño es que la
arquitectura cure y sane lo primero que
tendría que estar seguro es que la
arquitectura que estamos haciendo no
está lastimando a los usuarios que
habitan la arquitectura
lo que empezamos a hacer fue a
investigar alrededor del concepto del
dolor y los mecanismos del dolor y lo
que dijimos web
la evidencia más más sencilla y más
clara de que algo te hace daño es uno de
estos mecanismos que tenemos para
defendernos y para identificar que algo
no es bueno para ti y básicamente ese es
el dolor y entonces lo que hicimos fue
decir bueno qué sucede en ese mecanismo
y no me voy a meter en la parte
neurocientífica para no aburrirlos es
todavía muy temprano para para filosofar
tan tan tan profundo pero les voy a
explicar rápidamente cómo funciona sobre
simplificando el cerebro tiene tres
leyes si uno de los leyes es el cerebro
reptiliano que seguramente todos han
escuchado del cerebro reptiliano es el
que compartimos con muchos animales es
un cerebro lo sumamente básico y lo más
importante de entender del cerebro
reptiliano es que en el cerebro
reptiliano solo hay cosas de vida o
muerte el cerebro reptiliano la razón
por la que tenemos esa parte en el
cerebro es para sobrevivir
taccetti no hay nada más no hay nada
superficial como el lenguaje
como la imaginación
nada más sobrevivir
en el cerebro reptiliano hay una parte
que se llama cortes insular el cortes
insular es justamente la parte que se
activa cuando tú tienes un dolor físico
cuando te pegas o cuando te rompes una
pierna o cualquier dolor físico se
activa la parte y el cortes insular el
cortes insular normalmente le manda una
señal a la parte motriz y esta es la
explicación de por qué puedes poner tu
mano en el fuego y no necesitas ni
pensarlo no tienes que decir esto me
está doliendo que debería ser de con la
mano ahí la muevo tu cerebro en
automático mueve la mano y es parte de
ese mecanismo lo interesante de esto
es que primero el dolor evidentemente es
un mecanismo como le decía de vida o
muerte de sobrevivencia pero
recientemente científicos utilizando
estas herramientas tecnológicas se
dieron cuenta que en la vida del ser
humano hay otras tres cosas que que
utilizan ese mes el mismo mecanismo
otras tres cosas cotidianas que vivimos
normalmente que no vienen por los mismos
estímulos físicos entonces de alguna
manera no nos enteramos que duelen pero
sin embargo son otros tipos de dolor
desde el punto de vista neurológico
tienen las mismas consecuencias
estas son de la primera es el
aburrimiento la segunda es la falta de
socialización o inclusive la amenaza de
falta de socialización ni siquiera la
socialización en sí misma y la tercera
es la falta de estética
el aburrimiento y cada vez que hablo de
neurociencia mientras más me meto en el
tema y era algo que platicaba muchísimo
en la maestría de neurociencia cognitiva
mi conclusión es que somos cavernícolas
con herramientas sofisticadas porque
cada vez que hay algo que te vuela la
cabeza quizás no entiendo por qué pasa
eso la explicación es que cuando
estábamos en las cavernas la bla bla bla
oye pero porque percibes cómo percibes o
porque es de las memorias que no son
fijas y se modifican con el tiempo y por
qué es que cuando estábamos en las
cavernas hoy porque hay desviaciones
cognitivas solo como dicen en inglés los
vayas cognitivos porque cuando estabas
en las cavernas entonces al final lo que
tenemos que entender es que somos
muchísimo más básicos de lo que nos
hemos querido vender a nosotros mismos y
la primera es que somos cavernícolas con
herramientas sofisticadas y como
cavernícolas pasamos muchísimo tiempo en
la sabana africana y que creen los la
sabana africana si algo tiene es que no
es aburrida la sana sabana africana pge
pasa además de que tienes que estar como
súper pendiente porque si hay un ruido
por allá igual y león que te va a comer
pero además de eso es el sol se va
moviendo y los árboles se mueven todo es
dinámico tiene un caos que al cerebro le
engancha y le gusta mucho entonces por
miles de años vivimos en la sabana
africana que no era aburrida cuando tú
te mueves a un entorno aburrido qué es
lo que sucede a tu cerebro no le gusta y
por mecanismo de sobrevivencia le manda
una señal al cortes insular y después
todo lo que sigue después del cortes y
solares y lo mismo que si se estuvieran
torturando
la segunda es falta es la falta de
socialización o inclusive lo como les
decía la amenaza de falta de
socialización esta es otra vez cuando
éramos cavernícolas pues resulta que
nacimos bastante inútiles con una piel
que no es particularmente gruesa no nos
protege gran cosa no somos muy rápidos
no somos muy estén fuertes somos
bastante inútiles hasta yo diría que
hasta toda la vida no esté pero
particularmente cuando somos chiquitos y
entonces toda la naturaleza nos dotó con
una herramienta de sobrevivencia que es
la socialización una de las grandes
razones por las que hemos logrado
florecer como como sociedad es justo que
somos una sociedad es la construcción de
tribu una de las grandes herramientas
que nos ha dado la naturaleza para poder
sobrevivir en aislado no llegamos muy
lejos
pero nos tenía que dar la naturaleza
alguna herramienta para que esto
sucediera y funcionará porque si no pues
tú podías tener un hijo dejarlo ahí
tirado y éste si no había algo que te
conectará con el tolo cáustica y se
acabó porque a una a un bebé los 'paras'
de su madre y el bebé empieza a llorar
es una de las explicaciones es que le
duele la falta de socialización está
esta separación social activa el córtex
insular y al niño le sucede lo mismo que
si lo estuvieras golpeando o si
estuviera sufriendo dolor físico
y la falta de estética está esta en
particular me encanta porque vivimos en
un país pero no nada más méxico en
general en un mundo contemporáneo que
hemos analizado la importancia de la
estética
cuántas veces no entras en un proyecto
por lo menos los que estamos en el mundo
del diseño y cuando hay poco dinero lo
primero que dice no es bueno es quitarle
estas cosas aunque quede un poquito más
feito pues como que eso no importa es
como si fuera banal no como si la
estética fuera un tema de que si tienes
dinero y tienes privilegios
estética pero si no pues no bueno
resulta que han hecho estudios en los
que si tú pones una persona enfrente de
objetos que no considera estéticos el
cerebro activa el córtex insular y otra
vez es el estrés el desgaste etcétera
etcétera todo lo que viene después de
sufrir dolor empieza empieza a surgir
con eso
para entender para diferenciar aquí vale
la pena hacer una aclaración porque aquí
es muy común que la gente te diga oye
pero no la belleza está con el ojo que
en la mira son el cristal con el que la
miras hay que distinguir entre estética
y belleza la belleza es un constructo
social construido arriba de valores
estéticos pero los valores estéticos son
universales o sea si tú vas a áfrica y
lepe y haces un análisis de cómo
consideran una cara bella la simetría es
uno de los elementos con los que
consideran los africanos una cara bella
y si tú vas a nueva york y acs el mismo
estudio es lo mismo hay una serie de
valores universales estéticos que no
importa donde te pares en el mundo todas
las caras las vemos más bellas y son
simétricas
la estética es una gran herramienta de
toma de decisiones porque nos duele
porque cuando salías otra vez de la
caverna y eres un cavernícola ya había
una fruta podrida y una bonita
los que no tuvieron la capacidad de
decirme cómo las frutas bonitas se
murieron no nos pasaron sus genes y los
que nos pasaron sus genes fueron los que
agarraron esta capacidad dijeron yo nada
más voy a comer frutas bonitos los dos
están muy feas
y por qué duelen todas estas cosas
porque son otra vez herramientas de
sobrevivencia
sin embargo estamos llenos de espacios
aburridos pocos sociales y poco
estéticos
sistemáticamente como sociedad hemos
llenado al mundo de espacios aburridos
poco sociales poco estéticos que lo que
están haciendo es torturar a los
usuarios de esos espacios literalmente
esto no es una metáfora no estoy siendo
poético estamos torturando
neurológicamente a los usuarios de
nuestros espacios y lo peor es que
además muchos de estos espacios están
importadas de revistas nos hemos vendido
la idea de que de que el igual no están
tan mal
no tenemos que ir muy lejos para empezar
a ver los primeros ejemplos de esto
casi todas las escuelas que conozco
alrededor del mundo son pocos sociales
poco estéticas y aburridas
principalmente los salones de clase
ahora imaginen que tienen un grupo de
niños que tienen una accesibilidad un
poco mayor que el resto y esos niños los
metes en un salón en el que lo que le
estás diciendo el mensaje que le estás
mandando con la arquitectura es esto no
es bueno para ti muévete y no solo eso
lo estás torturando en ese mismo proceso
y luego del otro lado el que hace el
niño el niño se para y se mueve y que
hacemos de este lado otra vez lo
etiquetamos con déficit de atención y la
solución es correr y dar un medicamento
ahora no estoy diciendo que no existe el
déficit de atención evidentemente existe
y soy un buen ejemplo de eso pero lo que
sí estoy diciendo es que estamos
mandando los mensajes equivocados
estamos en este proceso haciendo un
estudio con unos socios en canadá en el
laboratorio de neurociencia justamente
para identificar cómo a través de diseño
yo podría reducir los síntomas con los
que al final después terminas
etiquetando estos niños de déficit de
atención
si queremos curar con arquitectura y
lograr este sueño algún día esto solo lo
vamos a lograr con la capacidad que
tengamos como sociedad de entender que
el espacio tiene un poder de transformar
la vida de las personas de manera
positiva y tomarnos no muy en serio
winston churchill decía en los
cincuentas después de la segunda guerra
mundial winston churchill tenía una
frase con la que logró que le dieran el
dinero para reconstruir la casa de los
comunes y lo que decía es que la
arquitectura que moldeamos nos moldea
después de regreso
yo creo que winston churchill tenía la
idea casi completa
pero si entendemos que la arquitectura
es cognición y que por otro lado los
nuestros los límites de nuestro cerebro
no están en nuestra mente no están en
nuestro cerebro no están en nosotros
sino que están en el espacio que nos
rodea lo que tendríamos que tener muy
claro es que todos somos arquitectura
todos somos espacio gracias
[Aplausos]